king charles iii who's just finished
this extraordinary speech
and i was going to say a few things off
the top which we scripted but i'm not
going to do that now because i feel like
the speech
has taken things over a little bit
because i was watching that with some
people and i said at the end what do you
think
and to a man and woman
they said he nailed it that was an
amazing speech
that's the kind of speech which
makes pubs go silent
which makes people think wow this is our
new king our mnemonic it's a big moment
for this country it's a big moment in
our history
and the speech i felt was perfectly
pitched it was the perfect length length
it hit all the right notes and it made
me feel as a british subject
confident about the way we're going to
be going
under this king someone who's been let's
remember
the longest reigning apprentice
to be a monarch that there's ever been
decade after decade wondering if he
would ever actually get the top job
and now through the appalling
circumstance of his mother's death and
imagine how difficult it is
to address the country and the world
literally hours after you've lost your
mother
that in itself
is a remarkable thing to be doing
and i thought king charles iii
absolutely nail the speech let's just
take a little look at some of that
speech again
to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear late papa
i want simply to say this
thank you
thank you
for your love
and devotion
to our family
and to the family of nations you have
served so diligently all these years
may
flights of angels
sing thee to thy rest
well it's going to talk tv's royal
editor sarah houston who's at buckingham
palace uh sarah i i was really moved by
that speech i got to be honest i didn't
know how charles was going to play it i
it was the biggest speech of his entire
life the most important the most
consequential
and of course done in the harrowing
backdrop of losing his mother and i
thought for all those reasons under the
huge pressure of the world watching i
thought he was absolutely brilliant
piers i agree with you wholeheartedly
he's had a long time to think about this
speech and craft this speech for this
moment
but it was a speech that really matched
the magnitude of the moment it it was
moving
it was touching
it gave us an insight into the kind of
king that charles iii will be
it was a speech of unity bringing people
together different nations different
faiths and bringing his own family
together reaching out to harry and megan
it was a speech where he honored
his late mother
um the bit that made me gulp was where
he talked about her last great journey
to join my dear papa
um
and
he praised his wife camilla
now the queen consort and particularly
given the images we saw earlier appears
of
the king and queen consult arriving here
at buckingham palace
those huge crowds
charles i think particularly moved and
buoyed by the reactions from the crowd
i thought camilla looked very emotional
um
and
i think this is overwhelming for her too
and we heard that in the speech as king
charles set out just what this means to
her
and the role that she will play in
supporting him and how important that is
yeah i mean i thought honestly when they
went on that walkabout
i was watching glued to the screen
wondering how well how's this going to
go what's the what you can't ever plan
for you can plan all the logistics you
can't plan for public reaction you've no
idea what's going to happen you've no
idea how the public is going to react
are they going to be pro this guy who's
our new monarch or not
and it was incredibly moving and
stirring
to watch
line after line of the british public
beginning to shout out
you know god save the king and start to
sing the national anthem with the new
lyrics of the king and i found it really
moving and then i saw a camilla who did
look emotional as indeed he looked like
he'd been very emotional but i think
they were also probably very taken aback
by the warmth of the crowd and the
reaction
uh you even had a woman leap forward and
plant a big kiss
on charles in fact we we've got her
later on the program um she'll be on the
show to talk about what it's like the
kid to be the first woman to kiss the
new king apart from his queen console um
i just found it really i bet she didn't
imagine that when she had her breakfast
this morning
but it was very and what was interesting
to me in the crowd people of all ages
all ethnicities this was real
cosmopolitan britain
meeting their new king for the first
time as king
and clearly loving him and i thought
that he i remember a few years ago right
well i would say a few weeks ago he went
down to the east end
and a similar situation happened with a
crowd and i remember watching that going
wow i've not seen him do that before and
that was great
and today i saw a lot more of it i want
to see a lot more of this from miss king
you know literally mingling with the
people because i think that is the way
forward for him what did you think
well it was his first walk about as king
at the walk about invented created by
his mother the queen who realized he
needed to be seen to be believed
and obviously at a moment of deep
personal grief and yet
he knew that he had to get out there
among the people and we were waiting for
someone from the royal family
to do that today i wasn't necessarily
expecting it to be charles because
so
somber and so significant were the
duties that lay before him today i
wondered if we might see prince william
or
the allen countess of wessex for example
coming out at balmoral earlier on today
but to see him there shaking hands with
people
taking the kisses receiving flowers
and the dynamics between he and camilla
were really interesting as well
she was just there behind him and then
she stepped aside and then he carried on
on the walkabout and then
he waited and took her with him and they
saw those flowers and one of the most
striking images that will stay with me
from today appears was of the two of
them walking through the gates of
buckingham yeah it was so powerful
wasn't it to face their future yeah in
their new home incredibly powerful yeah
in their new home uh sarah thank you
very much for that it was it was great
to watch it must have been great to be
down there i appreciate you giving us
that update